saij wrote in what major thing is on the
verge of happening soon kind of a
general question it's a tough one to
answer I do believe that in the area of
Medicine we are sort of on the verge of
significant advancements and I know that
it's become sort of cliche to say that
because we've been on the verge of
curing cancer for so long we've been on
the verge of extending human longevity
and lifespans drastically for a very
very long time or what feels like a long
time by our standards and it doesn't
really seem to be happening and part of
that is that unless you're exposed
regularly to certain worlds you don't
necessarily see the degree of
advancement the other thing is that when
you're in the middle of significant
change it can be difficult to see it my
sense is that two hundred and fifty
years from now when humans look back at
this period and the sort of 20 or 30
years that follow we will have seen
significant progress on a lot of medical
conditions I think that we are on the
verge of significantly improving our
space travel capabilities we are close
to going to Mars and I think that that's
going to open up a lot of new avenues
possibilities when it comes to humans
moving around in in space and of course
we've talked about how Steven Hawking
and others believe that that's an
absolute necessity for Homo sapiens to
survive really long term I think we're
also I'm this is more of a hopeful one
but I hope that we're on the verge of
having to restructure the way our
socioeconomic status sort of works in
the United States and around the world
and by this I mean that been between
automation and artificial intelligence
and robotics combined with drastically
increasing inequality in the world I'm
sort of hopeful that we're close to a
major change in how we structure the
relationship of humans to work for
example this relates to everything from
universal basic income to other
provisions that we've talked about those
are the major ones that I think of and I
don't know sage if you were thinking of
something else in particular but I think
that those are the ones that come to
mind for me and you know I don't follow
the medicine close enough to be able to
say more specifically this particular
disease or that particular disease is
very very close to being cured like for
example I know hemophilia
there's huge optimism that very soon we
will make just drastic strides in the
treatment of hemophilia I don't know
enough about it to really be able to say
more I know cancer is often the big one
that's discussed I also would be
interested and I think that it might be
more than five years away but maybe more
like 10 or 15 years away major strides
in the treatment of drug addiction I
think that the way that and I'm not
talking about it in a legal sense I know
that I've talked a lot about how the war
on drugs has failed and we should really
be treating drug addiction as a health
issue and not as a an issue of the
criminal justice system I'm talking
about treatment of addiction whether
it's opioid addiction the way that a lot
of states and their northeaster
suffering from or other drugs like
cocaine for example I'm hopeful that
we're gonna make big strides
pharmacologically and maybe even
therapeutically when it comes to the
treatment of drug addiction but again I
don't know exactly when that's going to
happen those are my thoughts send me
your thoughts if I missed any we've got
a great bonus show for you today and
please keep the audience questions
coming we are like to answer three at
the end of every Friday show they've
been very very good lately and we'll do
three more next week